as we reported earlier Jay Simpson could
soon walk free from a Nevada prison
Simpson was convicted in 2008 of armed
robbery kidnapping and other charges
after attempting to retrieve sports
memorabilia at a Las Vegas hotel today
he will go before a parole board to ask
for his release but it was the 1995
murder trial that seemed nted Simpson's
place in American history the football
phenom turned movie star was accused of
murdering ex-wife Nicole Brown Simpson
and Ron Goldman
The Washington Post writes quote OJ
Simpson's story represents one of the
most dramatic falls from grace in the
history of American pop culture attorney
Carl Douglas was part of Simpson's dream
team defense during the 1995 murder
trial he is joining us live from Los
Angeles so let me ask you first do you
think that we're going to hear release
today from the parole hearing I think so
really
he had a parole hearing in 2013 and he
was granted parole on seven of the 12
charges since then he's been a model
prisoner
there have been no write ups so there's
no reason for you to think that he won't
be paroled today as well do you think
this case what in particular made it so
striking to the American public who
became obsessed with it this has really
been the perfect storm of all things
that fascinate Americans first it was a
crime drama there probably are more
crime networks and crime shows on than
any other type of show second it was
celebrity indeed and we Americans have
always been fascinated by celebrity and
then you have to throw in as well the
Energizer of race when those three
components were thrown together clearly
it struck a chord with many Americans
Carl you ever think that a Joe Simpson
will speak to what happened I'm not sure
Charlie and he'll ever speak to what
happened in in 1994 but he may well talk
about things that were going on from his
most recent conviction in Nevada but
that not what people want to hear they
want to hear
his version of I don't think he'll ever
really give a sit-down concerning that
he was the quit of those charges that
probably is a part of his past and while
there always be a fascination about that
I don't think I would ever see him
sitting down and discussing that even
now Simpson received a maximum sentence
of 33 years in connection with the Vegas
hotel robbery and some say that that was
payback for his acquittal in the 1994
double murder case do you agree with
that I do I am one of those that think
certainly there was connection although
the judge would deny it from the
sentence that was given as well as what
happened in Los Angeles you got to
understand the verdict in that case was
13 years to the day October 3rd that
there was the verdict in the Los Angeles
trial the 33 year sentence mirrored the
33 and a half million dollars that was
the verdict against him in the civil
trial I don't think that was a
coincidence and I think it was really a
tragedy that he was punished for what
happened in Los Angeles you still talk
to OJ Simpson I haven't had a chance to
talk with him for more than 10 years the
last time that I saw Oh Jay was at
Johnnie Cochran's funeral in April 2005
one of the speakers there had asked
anybody who had ever been represented by
Johnnie to stand up I looked to the
church to my right and there was a Jay
Simpson and a few rows away was Michael
Jackson standing as well
it was a scene to remember Carl do you
think at the time of the trial there was
much written and said you know about how
different communities whether know the
african-american community or other
communities saw him is there a
difference today how different
communities see OJ Simpson you know I
think Charlie that the the distinction
between the opinions of the white
community and the black community are
far closer today 22 years later than
they were in 1995 I dare say that I
would suspect that probably a
geordie of african-americans would
probably believe that OJ Simpson was
responsible for the two deaths though
those numbers were far smaller back 22
years ago we were speaking with Ricky
Kleeman earlier our legal analyst and
she said that Oh Jay Simpson still has a
lot plenty of money he has a huge
pension my understanding is yes that he
gets $25,000 a month from his pension
with the NFL and there I think there is
another pension as well that he gets
from the Screen Actors Guild so I hope
that he has used and fade that money
well and he won't be strapped for cash
when he's released in October if he's
granted parole today yeah Ricky said
it's a pension of that could be worth
about twenty five million dollars and
that is protected from the Goldman's yes
it is those pensions are protected under
Florida law so they cannot be attached
for paying back the proceeds of the
verdict against him what do you expect
he will do with his life as a free man
if he is released he's 70 years old
he's 70 euros now I think oj the first
thing he's gonna want to do if he's able
to be paroled to Nevada to took to
Florida which was his home he is first
I'm sure going to reconnect with his
family he's the father of four children
I suspect he'll seek a little female
attention and then he'll return to his
greatest passion which is the Gulf it's
70 years and I'm not sure if his body
will portray him but I think for sure
he's gonna want to be back and be an
active role in at handling golf Oh Carl
after all these years is there one
question you wish you could answer about
OJ Simpson you know I probably have all
the answers Charlie to all the questions
that I've had over 22 years I've had
more than enough time to wrack my brain
and there's not really one question that
I haven't asked of OJ that I want to ask
him today all right all of them yeah for
sure all right Carl Douglas thank you
for joining us thank you for having me